vous avez d'abord raison de rappeler que
la France a perdu 41 de ses enfants dans
les attaques terroristes du 7 octobre
dernier ce qui fait de ces
attaques l'acte terroriste le plus
meurtrier depuis
Nice le 7 février prochain
au monument pour les victimes du
terrorisme jardin des Invalides je
rendrai hommage à ces victimes au côté
de leurs proches de leurs famille et de
tous ceux qui voud nous y rejoindre ce
sera 4 mois jour pour jour après
l'attaque
terroriste nous avons libérer qure
otages nous avons encore trois otages
qui sont détenus et nous nous battons
pied à
pied avec les autorités israéliennes
avec le Qatar qui a un rôle décisif en
la matière
avec aussi plusieurs autres collègues
pour les libérer je ne veux ici faire
aucune annonce parce que ces matières
sont toujours délicates et je pense
aussi aux familles
mais nous nous battons nous ne lâcherons
rien et j'espère que les prochains jours
prochaines semaines nous
permettront d'obtenir leur libération en
tout cas nous voulons tous les ramener
chez nous
ensuite cette attaque terroriste a
déclenché une réaction euh d'Israël et
des bombardements sans trêve depuis euh
maintenant euh plus de 100
jours en particulier sur la bande de
Gaza sur ce sujet peut-être reviendraije
si d'autres questions il sont posées la
France a une une approche qui depuis le
début a été de condamneré de manière
intraitable l'attaque terroriste d'avoir
au fond une réponse qui est la paix et
la sécurité pour tous lutter contre le
terrorisme l'approche humanitaire ce qui
nous a conduit à des aides humanitaires
et à une demande de cesser le feu et la
solution politique des deux états pour
ce qui est de l'humanitaire qui est
votre question nous avons mené une
action résolue et je dois le dire
inédite d pour un
pays occidental depuis le début d'abord
en déployant des militaires et tout des
moyens militaires et tout
particulièrement le Dixmude qui restera
jusqu'à la fin du mois et qui a déjà
permis de soigner plus de 1000 patients
enfants adultes avec un dévouement
extraordinaire des médecins qui sont
présents qui se sont relayés sur
celui-ci une coopération exemplaire avec
l'Égypte nous avons plus de 1000 tonnes
de fret de soutien d'aide y compris
médicaments qui ont été
livrés et nous avons en effet ces
dernières semaines mis en place des
opérations très délicate pour livrer de
l'aide dans la bande de Gaza même le 3
janvier dernier nous avons avec les
Jordaniens mener une opération pour
larguer justement des rations
alimentaires sur la bande de Gaza et
nous sommes en train d'agir nous avons
commencé à agir avec le Qatar pour en
effet dé livvrer des médicaments dans la
bande de Gaza et nous continuerons de le
faire avec tous les partenaires de la
région qui nous aident pour cette action
humanitaire qui a beaucoup mobiliser à
la fois nos militaires nos diplomates et
sur lesqueles nous travaillons aussi
avec beaucoup d'associations et d'ONG
qui sont absolument exemplaire dans
cette
[Musique]
action